every so often the enemy community is
graced with a rollercoaster of a show
and as an audience member once you've
committed to getting on the ride you
could either sit back accept that you're
here to the end and try to enjoy your
time or you can act like this darling in
the Fran xx is the latest roller coaster
to set this anime community on fire the
show had a lot of hype going into it
being the latest collaboration between
the famed a-1 pictures studio trigger
Hayao Miyazaki Fox News cannabis science
in wreck-it Ralph Sesame Street and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe for weeks
viewers have toiled over its many subtle
themes messages and symbolism but today
I will present a definite proof over
everything the show is trying to say
while ultimately assessing if this is
truly the next modern mecha masterpiece
or just another show that [ __ ] the bed
after high early expectations which you
know I'm not gonna name any names cuz
I'm not that kind of person we don't
[ __ ] talk here on this channel we start
with the title which if you look closely
is a clever nod referring to the main
character's name darling and the MEK is
that they pilot super kawaii momo robot
waifu death squad the basic premise is
about a bunch of angsty teenagers who
have to fight monsters in a
post-apocalyptic world and a lot of
people have compared this Evangelion but
after careful analysis over countless
seconds I can conclude that this has
absolutely no merit at all look guys not
every show about giant robots fighting
monsters in a post-apocalyptic world is
ripping off a favor I mean one has a
pilot who doesn't want to get in the
robot and the other one has one who
really really does there you go nothing
alike plus darling in the Fran xx is a
heavy heavy sexualized show and you know
Ava wasn't sexualized at all so there's
also a big difference there Plus a-1
pictures and studio Trigger are very
active studios while he react ya know is
never gonna give us a before point o now
in Evangelion you had these monsters
called angels and on the other side you
have clacks or sores which alike robot
dinosaurs which is totally different
because they have a core that needs to
be destroyed in order to kill
and the important thing is is setup so
they almost have to fight a different
monster every week so I don't know how
even getting on can even begin to
compare to bats let's not forget that
darling in the fran has a scene where a
pilot is just freaking out in the
cockpit and the idea for this scene was
something that was totally innovative in
the genre of mecha
Wow Evangelion or sad iconic scenes that
would be totally obvious if someone
copied them and I didn't see any kind of
resemblance at all so you might say well
what about these mysterious
organizations that seem to be
controlling everything and that's such a
superficial observation because then I
would say well where's Ava's two-pilot
system that directly depends on
synchronization levels ha ha and let's
not forget that in Fran only children
can pilot the mecca's so I don't know
how even gimme one could even begin to
compare to that and then these stupid
tickets still want to compare the two
because they both have biomechanical
mechs but then they obviously haven't
gotten to the twist yet when it's
revealed that the mechs they were
piloting are actually clacks er sores ha
ha ha that's right they were piloting
the monsters they were fighting this
entire time you stupid [ __ ] I don't know
how you found Gallion can't even begin
to compare to that this is not to
mention the colorful cast we are
presented with right off the bat we are
introduced to a naked pink haired 0-2
you're merging like a goddess and of
course our main character darling is
immediately like oh yeah this definitely
smells like breasts girl later we see
their relationship develop and even have
a backstory revealed and as you can see
here the results are clear as after
years of funding and research we are
finally getting closer to a cure for
cancer an interesting facts you may not
know is that everyone's name corresponds
to their code number in Japanese for
example zeros to name in Japanese would
be Oh need only which in Japanese
folklore is a kind of demon character
with horns
similarly code 0 1 5 Ichigo can be split
into itchy and go it she go 1 5 which
represents the exact number of people
who legitimately thought she was best
girl there was such a big cast it can
get hard to remember names
it's much easier to remember them by
their unique code names Tucker cocky
[ __ ] Lord
I don't give a [ __ ] LGBT [ __ ] my big fat
[ __ ] wedding you cooking what may the
cockle brother and of course [ __ ] me
harder daddy love triangles are a
popular trope in anime but darling in
the Fran xx manages to take this to the
next level with such intricate character
relationships you need a far more
complicated shape to keep track of it
all you start with zero - who is a clone
of zero 1 and is in the simple love
triangle of darling and Ichigo however
each girl has other characters who are
interested in her in Goro and eco no
darling on the other hands used to share
a close relationship with meat Saru who
really ended up with kokoro who was
loved by futoshi creating this big line
meanwhile Miku and ziram are just doing
their own thing closed off from everyone
else so if we put this all together you
can see that it off the [ __ ] so much
discussion has been had over the actions
of the cast members with criticism being
thrown in every direction but upon
closer inspection every single action
makes perfect sense and has a deeper
meaning behind it this controversial
kiss garnered a lot of hate for Ichigo
with critics analyzing every frame of
this to come to the conclusion that this
was the classic literary tactic we know
as a dick move but looking deeply into
the scene many may have missed the
subtext of what he was trying to say see
episode 14 aired in April of 2018
exactly nine years after legal legend
started closed beta testing not only
that but if we add all the code numbers
of the three members present we get 87
eight seven patch 8.7 of legal legends
was released in April 2018 and that's
when I understood this kiss represents
League of Legends international
tournament performances and Goro is na
anyone familiar with trigger shows and
the history of their staff we know that
they sometimes like to put in the odd
sex metaphors in their work now when
darling in the fran you have to look
really carefully but if you do you may
be able to spot some sexual metaphors
like for example one obvious one was
when 0/2 offered bread dipped in honey
this is reference to honey
pet-name married couples can often refer
to each other as hinting at consummating
their relationship which in marriage
obviously refers to sexual intercourse
that's the only one I could find deep
appreciation also has to be given for
what this has done for the genre of
Mecca when we think of giant robots in
the iconic genre of Mecca you may be
reminded of metallic goliaths marvels of
human engineering a cultural icon that
has inspired the fields of robotic in
real life and what's so incredible about
this show is that he has the balls to
look at these and go [ __ ] that no
literally [ __ ] that I want to [ __ ] giant
robots and made Lou double giant robots
in an interview with the mecca designer
about where he got his inspiration for
these revolutionary designs he was noted
for applying with the single line where
there's a will there's a way
to stick your dick in it and this leads
us to the latter part of the series
where we finally gets an explanation
about the world and history in episode
19 for you see I'm sorry I accidentally
hit the fast-forward button there let me
guess back on track
what
[Music]
what I don't know why there are aliens
or why there are space battles or who
Verma or what the [ __ ] is going on so
you know I must have accidentally
skipped a whole season let me check this
it's still HEPA so 20 what it was at
this moment that I had an epiphany maybe
the show about Aang's team's piloting
giant robots using the power of but sex
wasn't the revolutionary show I thought
it was gonna be now I don't know what
the creative process behind having such
a big plot turn so late in the series
was but according to some sources it
went a little something like this
okay it's episode 20 what do we have
planned this is when you want to add the
aliens did I say that triggers in the
house now
what do you go butI but it's a
[ __ ] alien that doesn't sound
like me well at least we have another 25
episodes to flesh this out actually the
show is too cool what do you mean it's
only too cool
it means we only have 24 episodes but as
I looked deeper things just didn't add
up why aliens why are they called berm
wait a minute
vorm a vampire how a vampire is involved
could this be a metaphor for alien
sucking the life force out of Earth as
had been explained in the exposition or
was alex jones the writer for this the
entire time there's a psychic vampire
stealing the energy from the kids it's a
vampire conspiracy in that they are
inter-dimensionally sucking the essence
of our youth right and they believe
they're possessed by an offworld entity
how many of the staff members were
really involved was any information we
were given accurate at all driven i
searched hard to see if i could find any
evidence but unfortunately there were
zero resources available to me as my
anime this was still under maintenance
and then it hit me the [ __ ] fess asked
worshiping angsty giant robot show was a
front this was a diversion orchestrated
by a grand mastermind in order to pull
the wool over
eyes over the truth this was no a one
pictures project there was no studio
trigger involvement so you may be
wondering who is responsible it was
hitting a key I know all along you
[ __ ] idiot
this was able 4.0 the entire time wake
up America hey guys thank you very much
this month to Nicolas Tatum sundown fun
me team at Lebanon sisters one zero zero
eight six Elif all Robert on Borg and
everyone else on patreon for helping to
support me for this month and making
this video possible
sorry no video of me and not many
updates today as I am back from a X I am
so exhausted I am about to collapse so I
don't really want to show my face right
now so I don't know what to say right
now thanks for watching if you liked the
video subscribe and don't forget to
smash that like button
no obliterate that like button no
[ __ ] destroy that like button right
now you worthless piece of [ __ ] have a
great day